y
[Música]
buenas tardes
en todas las épocas hemos tenido
personajes de ficción que eran nuestros
héroes y nuestras heroínas influyen de
alguna manera en nuestras elecciones
porque los tomábamos como modelos eran
los modelos a imitar y dan como espejos
en los cuales nos mirábamos
cuando era adolescente había una serie
de televisión que era la de la mujer
maravilla'
la mujer maravilla era el máximo
exponente de belleza de inteligencia de
fortaleza creo que muchas mujeres de mi
generación queríamos ser como ellas pero
bueno claro y vamos creciendo nos íbamos
dando cuenta que había mucha diferencia
entre estos personajes de ficción y
nosotros
una característica común de estos
personajes era que atravesaban todo tipo
de peligros se enfrentaban con sus
adversarios sus enemigos pasaban todo
tipo de adversidades y nunca les pasaba
nada ni un rasguño tenían
el tomar como modelos a estos personajes
nos podría hacer sentir disminuidos
porque solamente ellos que tenían todos
estos superpoderes podían atravesar la
adversidad y seguir sus vidas como si
nada pasara y sin embargo nosotros los
seres humanos no teníamos esas
capacidades ni esos poderes
pasó el tiempo y me recibí de psicóloga
hace unos 30 años que me dedico a la
psicología clínica he escuchado muchas
historias de muchas personas que han
atravesado situaciones muy difíciles y
de mucha adversidad pero iba notando que
estas personas tenían una fuerza de vida
como un deseo de vivir un poderoso
anhelo de supervivencia que les salía
después de atravesar una adversidad
entonces me dediqué a investigar esto
una paciente en un momento crítico de su
vida se había autolesionado en los
brazos y cuando comenzó a recuperarse se
tatuó flores encima de las cicatrices
otra paciente había sido abandonada por
su madre biológica había sido maltratada
de múltiples formas por su familia
adoptiva padeció abuso emocional y
cuando comenzó a recuperarse empezó a
desplegar una capacidad artística que
tenía una capacidad que tenía dormida y
se dedicó al reciclado de objetos
aquello que parecía inservible o
destruido ella hacía una obra de arte
estos tendrían que ser nuestros ejemplos
inspiradores gente que logró superarse
que logró superar tal vez alguna grave
enfermedad obstáculos muy grandes
limitaciones o a veces una pérdida muy
dolorosa a diferencia de estos
personajes de ficción
estos son nuestros héroes y heroínas
reales
seguramente como muchos de ustedes
también y que no salen ni en el cine ni
en la televisión ni en las redes ni en
las revistas cualquiera esta fuerza que
aparecía de qué se trataba esta fuerza
la respuesta la tuve cuando encontré en
mi propia fuerza mi propia fortaleza no
lo encontré de un momento para otro
porque no hay magia en esto encontré
después de un largo proceso de cambio de
transformación de trabajo interior
y el camino estuvo lleno de matices y
altibajos
el pasaje transformador
que va desde el pesimismo y la oscuridad
hacia un optimismo realista tenía un
nombre y se llamaba resiliencia
la murga en el río de la plata' nace
bajo la influencia de otro movimiento
artístico que era la chirigota de cádiz
españa se expandió rápidamente por
provincias de la argentina y también por
varios países de américa latina había
una característica común si bien cada
manifestación tenía sus características
autóctonas pero lo común era que la
murga aparecía siempre en carnaval
la murga en el río de la plata' nace
cuando los esclavos se crean momentos de
alegría a través del baile con bombos y
platillos para equilibrar esa vida de
dolor de desarraigo y de oscuro encierro
que tenían los ricos les prestaban sus
galeras y sus trajes y ellos los daban
vuelta para que los brillos del raso
acompañaron aún más esta transformación
y este espíritu festivo hay uno de los
bailes
la murga que es el de los tres saltos en
los que el esclavo
salta pega patadas al aire para
liberarse de las cadenas que tenían en
sus pies
de vidas que parecían asignadas por la
adversidad ellos se generaban a sí
mismos un renacimiento
oído el ruido de rotas cadenas dice
nuestro himno las cadenas interiores
esas que me atan no puedo son las más
difíciles de cortarlos
qué es ese sonido eso que suena
cuando atraviesa una adversidad
puedo creer que nada tiene sentido
pero al poco tiempo es posible que
vuelva a escuchar los latidos de mi
corazón otra vez
si vuelvo a escuchar los latidos de mi
corazón es probable que algo o alguien
me haya ayudado a despertar este corazón
dormido ese alguien o ese algo a veces
es una persona conocida o una persona
desconocida una película una frase una
charla ted la mirada de un niño una
música que suena oa veces son los bombos
y los platillos
si puedo volver a escuchar los latidos
de mi corazón quiere decir que estoy
viva que la adversidad no me quebró
totalmente y que puedo renacer
entonces mi mirada empieza a cambiar y
empiezo a ver brillos y colores que
antes no veía la glosa de la murga me
acerca a lo sensible a la poesía me
devuelve el sentido de pertenencia y me
recuerda a donde estoy y cuál es mi
misión
el movimiento de quienes tengo alrededor
me incita al movimiento me hace salir
del lugar donde estoy si yo puedo dar un
paso y salir del lugar donde estoy
significa que puedo salir del lugar
de víctima y puedo ser protagonista
el traje de la murga es como la nueva
piel esa nueva piel que nace después de
una quemadura o de una herida
los adornos que tienen los trajes que
cada uno pone de acuerdo a sus gustos e
intereses son como tatuajes cuantos más
adornos tiene un traje más le estoy
mostrando al mundo la fortaleza que
tengo para superar la adversidad
entonces empieza a aparecer una alegría
una alegría profunda si soy capaz de
tener una alegría profunda a pesar del
dolor significa que en algún momento voy
a poder transmitir esta alegría a otros
porque la alegría siempre se contagia
si puedo renacer de mis cenizas
si puedo encontrar alguna respuesta de
por qué y para qué me pasó lo que me
pasó si puedo ubicar ese hecho dentro de
mi biografía aún con dolor pero con una
mayor aceptación significa que en algún
momento seguramente voy a poder ayudar a
otros a atravesar ese proceso
todo esto es resiliencia
[Música]
la murga con sus latidos las glosas que
aumentan mi empatía
las canciones alegres que aumentan mi
alegría
el movimiento que me lleva al movimiento
la críptica y la picardía que tienen las
letras que me recuerdan que el humor
sana
los saltos que me recuerdan que soy
libre de elegir mi destino y con la
fortaleza y el poder
que me da el traje puesto puedo decir
que soy resiliente y que amo a esta vida
el máximo poder
que todos tenemos dentro todos tenemos
dentro para desarrollar se llama
resiliencia
el poderoso motor que activa a la
resiliencia se encuentra en el cerebro
aquí donde va la galera el que el lugar
del cuerpo donde se concentra esa
poderosa energía es el corazón hay un
autor que dice que la resiliencia es el
arte de metamorfosear el dolor para
dotarlo de sentido es la capacidad de
ser felices aún teniendo heridas en el
alma
soy integrante de la agrupación murguera
a troche y moche muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]